es un gran triunfo político el
presidente López Obrador el presidente
López Obrador está obsesionado con
que su Movimiento Político
tenga un poder casi omnímodo en en todo
el país México es un país Federal para
que nos escucha en otras partes del
mundo esto significa que ganar
gubernaturas significa tener poder
político control de congresos estatales
control de gobernadores
presupuestos económicos por supuesto
entonces
la Joya de la corona para el presidente
López Obrador era el estado de México el
estado de México Ese es el estado que
rodea a la Ciudad de México es el estado
más poblado del país con el casi el
diecisiete por ciento de la población de
México más de 16 millones de habitantes
lo cual junto con la Ciudad de México
tiene una es una
con urbe de veinticinco millones de
personas
mucho más que que muchos países de
Centroamérica El Caribe y Sudamérica Qué
significa esto también Mara Clara el
próximo año hay elecciones
presidenciales en México y el haber
ganado el estado de México le da una
posición muy relevante al presidente
López Obrador para aclara y por el otro
lado como entender la derrota de los dos
partidos tradicionales el partido Acción
Nacional pan y el pri que venían de
gobierno sucesivos entre ellos
Mira este era el gran bastión priísta
el pri recordarle a tu auditorio gobernó
71 años México y también regresó con
Enrique Peña Nieto y fue uno de los
gobiernos más corruptos en la historia
reciente del país
el partido revolucionario institucional
el pri Solamente le quedan dos gobiernos
estatales cuando en la transición a la
democracia con el presidente Vicente Fox
llegó a gobernar 19 estados a pesar de
que no tenía la presidencia de la
República esto nos da que el pri está en
la antesala de la prácticamente
desaparición política y el pan está
igual el partido Acción Nacional que
impulsó al presidente Felipe Calderón y
al presidente Vicente Fox se encuentra
gobernando solamente cinco estados de la
república Entonces estamos viendo una
aplanadora contra la oposición para
aclarar